Justin hey Walt here with a gamespot  news update an image spotted online  suggests that Ubisoft open-world game  watch dogs may have a closed beta coming  up before its launch on May 27th a  screenshot of the xbox games store  spotted on reddit shows an xbox one  closed beta download weighing in at 23  gigabytes the game listing reads you or  aiden pearce a brilliant hacker but also  a former thug whose criminal past leads  to a violent family tragedy at a world  led by technology you'll be able to hack  and manipulate the city's systems to  stop traffic lights detonate gas lines  turn off the electrical grid and more  the city of Chicago has become the  ultimate weapon for a man bent on  revenge the text in the listing is very  similar to descriptions for watchdogs  previously written by Ubisoft Ubisoft  declined to comment to us on the  watchdogs beta but for developing news  on the game as it releases be sure to  stay tuned to gamespot